do you think this team's really long you
know it's old school maybe but a very
cliche a chip on their shoulder or not I
hope so yeah I mean I hope so you know
it's um whatever we can use for
motivation you know I mean and I think a
lot of our guys to be honest they may
not admit this or not you know uh you
win game one of the playoffs and all
everybody talked about was the Lakers
let's be honest I was a national
narrative was hey the Lakers are fine
they're down 1-0 but they figured
something out
no one talked about Nicola just had a
historic performance
he's got 13 triple doubles now third
all-time what he's doing is just
incredible but the narrative wasn't
about the nuggets the narrative wasn't
about Nicola the narratives about the
Lakers and their adjustments
so you know you put that in your pipe
you smoke it and you come back and you
know what we're going to go up to a do
you think that narrative changes tonight
well I don't care if it does yeah I mean
because we know our narrative in that
locker room we know that we're not done
we haven't done anything yet all right
you got to win a game on the other
team's home court if you really want to
do something in a series and we know how
great that team is especially on their
home court so uh we're not celebrating
you know this is not cause for
celebration this is the cause to
continue to dig deep and find ways to be
better